well hello baby girl how are you today
so good it's Christmas Eve oh yeah that
your child loves Christmas just have fun
christmase Christmas Dad isn't that nice
sound like wounded
ducks and what was
that do you mind telling me what you're
doing in my chimney can you see me
what's your name my name is Nicholas
Santa
Claus what is this those a carrots the M
said I need to eat healthier so she
think this would Wing me off the cookies
has worked so far if you're really Santa
tell me what Charlotte wants for
Christmas she wants a pretend makeup kit
and scooter he's right see Dad I've
never met an 8-year-old girl that did
not want a pretend makeup
set man who are they it looks like a a
snowman an elf and a nutcracker AKA
every Tuesday at my house got a dash yes
oh no what is going on those bad guys
are acting my naughty and Nic list but I
got some Associates here you Eddie's a
nonbeliever really oh claustrophobic I'm
sorry what claustrophobic fear of Santa
Claus that's
ludicrous I get it you don't believe but
I have to deliver Christmas gifts
tonight Dad we need to help him where
are you guys weth Santa Claus and heats
glitter and there's these people and
they aren't actually El bring my child
home why should still have a white beard
i d it if I want to look younger I
deserve that how can these two out Fox
us out run us all I want to do is Havey
start believing
again what you about to witness is a
sleigh being pulled by eight beautiful
reindeer let mispaired the
Bluetooth Christmas who do you work for
some people think I work for mother
nature or father time recently everybody
thinks I work for Beyonce but no every
married man want understand this I work
for Mrs
CLA